any sufficiently advanced technology
is indistinguishable from magic
welcome everyone to a very special
edition of the into the impossible
podcast
featuring your shirley dr brian keating
of the university of california san
diego
where i am joined today remotely joined
from the weizmann institute all the way
in israel
by a very very legendary figure in the
field of cosmology and especially in the
field of searching for dark matter and
potential alternatives to dark matter
and even alternatives to our theory of
gravity and that's professor mordecai
mutti
milgram who as known to many of you but
uh i will read his introduction uh at a
later date as we go on throughout this
conversation but mate uh lila tov how
are you
it's evening here yeah early in the
morning in san diego
yes yes so you might hear some kids
getting ready to go to summer camp so i
was introduced to you many many decades
ago now i mean you're very very famous
in the field of cosmology
but most recently by a mutual friend
over shilling who was a guest on the
podcast i'll put a link to that
somewhere up here or over there i don't
know in the video and then on audio
you'll be able to find it for his new
book called the elephant in the universe
which is called subtitle is 100 year
search for dark matter and he mentions
you he actually mentions you in the very
same paragraph almost as he mentions my
late great colleague
professor margaret burbidge
who was the mentor and friend to vera
rubin
and i want to start first by uh talking
when vera rubin visited uc san diego
where i am she worked with margaret and
margaret actually taught her how to do
rotation curve analysis so i want to
start with a little bit of history
the idea of modified newtonian dynamics
mod what is it and how did the idea come
to you
so uh basically you may know and the
audience may know that one of the
most central
questions puzzled in astronomy in
cosmology today
is what most of the universe is made of
in very few words
what happens is when you study galaxies
and study the motions of
constituents in those galaxies like
motion of stars and gas
and we use this motion to determine the
gravitational pull of the whole galaxy
on this complete constituent
we find that the gravitational pull is
much stronger than one one calculates
just uh taking the observed mass
distribution in
[Music]
those galaxies and calculating the
gravitational force using standard
dynamics
which is the coef newton and also
general relativity in other words there
is a large discrepancy
between the gravitational pull that is
needed to explain the motions
of constituents in galaxies and systems
of galaxies
the discovery between these and what the
observed matter in those galaxies can
supply
now i took another fork at the time this
was the
late late 1970s
early 80s
and uh with the proposal that the
problem the discrepancy does not result
from
the presence of yet undetected matter
but rather from the fact that we're not
using correctly the laws of physics to
calculate garbage
so that's
an alternative would be okay you're
using
let's say newtonian dynamics which is
the combination of the newton's law of
gravity
and the law of inertia you use this
combination of laws to calculate
how our
how stars should move in galaxies and
they actually
defy this result by by moving much
faster
and get calculated so okay maybe you are
not using the right laws
or maybe these laws are correct but only
have a limited range of validity
but after all we know that they have
been tested
successfully tested in the laboratory in
the solar system so that there are large
phenomena that are well explained by
these laws but perhaps in galaxies
of galaxies in the universe at large
this is not so
so that is essentially the the main idea
then you ask how it occurred to me so i
want to mention perhaps that
[Music]
but first of all in my background i did
my phd in particular few weeks
in the early 70s and then i switched
here to last phoenix
and initially for several years i worked
with so-called high-energy astrophysics
that need to do with
explosive or cataclysmic phenomena
such as they called neutron stars texas
a meeting starts and so on
but towards the late 70s i decided to
switch fields
and i looked around
and
[Music]
this issue of the
discovery that i mentioned before that
just began to
read its head
in a very meaningful way
partly due to of course observation of
but also one should mention
alongside with the contribution of
moving that that also works in the
netherlands using
radio telescopes not the optical
telescopes that they know because but
the radio telescope
measured the attraction
and the results of all of them
showed quite clearly that this problem
exists so this stuck me as an
interesting
field or a problem to start working on
when i start you know
make this decision to switch fields and
i also happen to be going to
about to be going to a sabbatical at the
institute for advanced studies in
brainstorming
and winston is the center of uh galaxy
dynamics you might say that
they still are but
there are quite a few world experts in
galaxy dynamic so my decision was
just to go and uh spend this sabbatical
year to study the field
prepare myself to
embark on this uh
this issue now um to tell the truth from
the beginning
i had a sort of
a guiding
idea
so i didn't just go deciding okay i work
on this field but
was something about those rotation kills
that started me
apparently
not have the same effect on others but
anyway to me it appears quite
interesting and there was that
well let me just explain what the
rotation curve is basically a
measurement of the
rotation that you know these galaxies
stars and gas moving more or less
circular motion it's not exactly more or
less circular and they're moving in a
disk and in a plane so so it's a curve
that protects the measurement of the
rotational speed
of
stars let's just say or gas in a galaxy
as a function of the
of the distance from the center
of the ring this would be very analogous
to say
telling us what what is the rotational
speed of the planets around the sun
when you plot them against the distance
from the sun the radius of the orbit
and suddenly as you go further and
further outside the galaxy you expect
this rotational velocity to go down
just as you find in the solar system
that the rotational speed of the planet
becomes lower and lower as you go to the
outer and outer planets of the
rotational mercury
with the highest than you can go out of
venus
the earth mass and so on the rotational
speed always decreases
and people expected that to happen in
galaxies as well because you
did not go down
they sort of remained flatish they
tended to
they went up at first and then they
didn't change much it went
out
and and
that the fact that the
velocity stayed high
and did not go down
the basis for the the discrepancy
so the calculated velocity was going
down
the measured velocity was not
state
straight up and uh it's just the
difference
it speaks
a discrepancy which
they said is the standard they
explained with that method but
another thing i you know i remember
telling myself okay if it's due to dark
matter
and that matter is there you know it
could be more could be less
density could
change in different ways in different
galaxies
why should the the business apparently
[Music]
then i said to myself well maybe it's
not that matter maybe
there is some
general law
that dictates this that the rotation
just should stay flat
this is this is actually
[Music]
when i went to princeton in fact i i
came across the idea which finally
started my working on morning so only
towards my state there so for the world
in india
just studying the field
learning about galaxies how they behave
but always with the view
to
finding perhaps some underlying
modification of the laws of
physics that utilize this behavior
[Music]
and often oftentimes when i give a when
i have a gaston to talk about
um
say dark matter or uh even specifically
talking about
uh beer ruben in particular i get emails
from her estate or sorry from zwicky's
uh relative so i get emails from or text
messages or
or uh comments on my videos uh saying
that vera rubin you know it was not
involved it really wasn't her discovery
it was all my father's wiki um and i
wonder
you you talk obviously you've been
speaking mostly about rotation curves
but in your uh in the early days the
earliest days of course wiki
was of course the you know the person
who coined the term in german at least i
think uh govern convinced me that it was
actually a dutch physicist captain who
coined it in english for some reason and
then ort etc but why start with rotation
curves why not start as wiki did with
the dynamics of clusters which are also
the you know kind of most massive bound
gravitational objects in the universe
why start with galaxy rotation curves
instead of clusters as wiki did
so so the apologies for this should not
be mined but the name of the whole
community that might whatever in the 30s
tricky indeed
uh pointed out
this satisfaction at least that again
the galaxies that are the constituents
of clusters of galaxy
also not also but move is the law
the velocity is higher than expected
when expected means that uh what you
calculate this
this is an elliptical galaxy but
there is also a transparency of a
cluster of the other things somewhere
yeah
okay so but that that's an elliptical
galaxy it's not it's not a cluster right
galaxy but um at any rate so vicky
pointed out that uh
yeah the velocities of galaxies in
clusters are much too high to be
explained
by that by the pool of the conditional
pool produced just by the observed
matter in those clusters
and then he said okay to explain this he
also invoked
dartmouth but what happened to this idea
between the 30th and let's say mid to
late 17th
study just disappeared and nobody talked
about it
you can only speculate
about the reason
but i suspect that
people just heard that
this system were not understood so well
so as to
to actually infer this so
you know it happens many times in
astrophysics
some measurements are misinterpreted
unjustified and anyway whatever the
reason was it was forgotten i never had
never heard about it
before
and
in addition i think the rotation just
really brought on the problem
to the community in much sharper terms
because rotation kits are
more accurately measured
so i i just say one thing you know
in clusters okay
what we can measure are just one
component of the velocity
galaxy in the cluster you know we use
doppler
effect to measure velocity and that
gives you only the component of the
velocity along the line of sight right
but to actually determine uh the
gravitational pull
and then object you need it all
it's not enough to have it it's uh you
know one component of its velocity
and you you didn't have that in clusters
so but in the rotation class you do
because because you know that the motion
in predictable
and by looking at the electricity of the
galaxy on the sky you can tell what its
inclination is to the line of sight
so you can you can you can translate
just this
measured one component of the velocity
to the full orbit
so
in the case of rotation curves you
actually do have the full orbit
and it tells you exactly
it is too high and very much i like to
see what the actual gravitational
so that may have been part of
why people may have said okay you know
maybe the components of the velocity in
other directions
no no
so so it did bring the issue
[Music]
but maybe also the you know the
it was the time was
more right for this
there were more people interested in
galaxy dynamics in the community and so
on so it depends on
[Music]
perceptive ground
so um again going back to you know how i
came to have you on the podcast today
uh we go to
the book by governor chilling who
features you extensively throughout it
and um again this is this is coming into
the work uh that is really you know kind
of
uniquely identified with with you i
would say which is this modification and
what he talks about he says i came
across the work of mordecai milgram
probably in the 1988 book dark matter by
wallace and karen here was someone with
a fresh take on a nagging cosmic mystery
while astronomers were becoming
convinced that flat rotation curves of
galaxies and the dynamics of clusters
could only be explained by assuming that
the universe was dominated by dark
matter milgram took another approach he
tried to change the laws of physics now
here was something heroic so first of
all um besides the fact that you're a
sabra uh
what gave you the the chutzpah to not
only take on you know uh changing the
laws of physics but take on isaac newton
uh you know who's considered by many the
father of modern physics uh if not all
of science so what gave you that
confidence um to go
as i always like to ask what gives you
the confidence to go into the impossible
the namesake of this of this podcast uh
how did you you know come to say well
actually it's going to be even more
important to go and change the laws of
physics
at the time or at least as far as i
remember myself that it was such a good
spot
in first because my background is from
particularly physics and uh
people dare to
explore
less less conventional
ideas and you know astrophysics uh let's
face it
more conservative field i should say
in a way i i i you know i i'd say
that
people like other
physicists invent the tools when
astrophysicists use them
so they don't like the tools to take
innovations and
so anyway whatever
seems to me that the community foster
this is more or at least at the time had
been more conservative
but uh
i didn't at the time actually he thought
it took a lot of courage to come up with
it and said well
why not i mean there's this idea let's
try it
if it works it works if it doesn't done
we may come back to this issue
later
we failed
short time but anyway
and
you know i was even sure that
once i came out people would just jump
on the bible and start working on it and
so and i was completely wrong you know
but at any rate
[Music]
i i guess that later on when i already
saw what the reaction of people eat
they take more couch than just coming
before you know before i actually knew
how people would react but
[Music]
[Music]
from the beginning i had some very good
collaborators
with the late jacob beckenstein and you
know it was enough that's uh you know it
wasn't me too many times
or something
and i had him and he expressed a lot of
confidence in the idea something was
enough for me
[Music]
after some time
yeah i want to get to
jacob in a bit but um
but first you know when i think about
this this story uh my younger listeners
may not be as familiar uh but there was
a very famous episode in the history of
astronomy where the same person
came up with two different approaches to
the problem of dark matter
and that was uh that was a person a
french mathematician
with a very strange first name urban
and the last name laverie
yeah
and he first was the one to take
observations and make a prediction that
neptune
was causing the anomalous
behavior of um of the orbit of uranus
which was the farthest planet known at
the time
it turns out that galileo actually
accidentally discovered neptune although
he didn't realize it in some
observations he made of jupiter just
completely serendipitously neptune was
there in the background and he thought
it was a star but anyway besides that uh
la verrier
he hypothesized that there must be some
unseen form of another planet i i you
know that is a form of dark matter that
was
previously unseen that was causing the
strange interaction is tugging on the
orbit of of uranus and the planet uranus
and then a few and then he was proven
right uh he was actually observationally
verified
and then maybe pushing his luck uh he
then uh went out and predicted
the explanation of the strange
peculiarity of mercury's orbit which was
another planet uh that was behaving
badly and he said this technique worked
well for me so why don't i postulate
dark matter is the explanation for
mercury and he postulated the existence
of an unseen planet called vulcan
and so he was right uh and then he was
wrong and uh i wonder which do you think
was a bigger you know was there a
mistake or blunder and then maybe you
can explain what einstein did to correct
the error of le verrier uh and why that
was so important
like well
it's a very happy analogy that's what is
dark matter because
you see emotions unexplained motion of
something
in a system that is obviously governed
by gravity
so in one case uh
[Music]
the
the less daring shall we say like what
is this of just some other body in the
system that you don't see and
contribute to the property did work
that was the first example you gave
in the other case i i wouldn't call it a
mistake i think it was the right
approach
not not just because it succeeded once
but because it was at the time the more
straightforward explanation so it was
not that it was well it turned out to
not be the right explanation
but he should judge uh
something
as being a mistake or not by
how things look at the time it was made
i'm very clear
so anyway so the indeed so
the planet uh milky way also showed some
very small now and normally in its
behavior
again when you calculated the effect of
all the known planets of the sun of
course from the motion of mercury and
it moved in almost the expected way but
not quite
it was a very small anomaly
and
i einstein was working on general
relativity
not
in order to explain this anomaly
which was not the case
in my case
i did suggest the alternative
uh
with my motivation of explaining the way
that matters but that's not the way he
talked about einstein had this theory of
special relativity
in 1905.
you were especially
he says that there is nothing that
can propagate faster than light and
according to the theory of neutron if
you shake
an object here
this is felt
right away at any distance
which means that the effect of gravity
of changes in gravity
in the mass of the producer propagating
into infinity
that does not include special locations
so one motivation launch that was to
find a
generalization of newtonian gravity that
will
adhere to the principle of special
activity and another motivation was to
actually generalize
okay so special relativity to tell you
that
physics looks the same in in systems
that move
with respect to each other
but only if they move
at a constant speed
[Music]
their special relativity is about
essentially about
distance moving at the constant speed
perspective then especially it tells you
how the laws of physics
but i wanted to generalize these two you
know just general emotions
and and you don't have to answer both
questions uh in one first one when the
introduction of
the theory of general that i think which
of course takes its name from the fact
that it is
generalizing special relativity but it
is also not just
this it is also a
relativistic of gravity
so it is an extension
generalization of newtonian team
and
it does predict small departures from
the calculation of newtonian gravity
even for planets
now its effects are very small in the
planetary system
activity kicks in
or departs from
newtonian dynamics when you're not
dealing with velocity that are
nearly right
near the speed of light or function and
which is the function
[Music]
um
[Music]
you may have heard that people are now
talking about planet nine
yes
yeah we're searching for it with the
simon's
observatory and the act the
common cosmology telescope is searching
for we can see it with microwaves
because anything above absolute zero of
course he missed that and then yeah we
are looking for planet nine but it's in
the opposite direction it's not
it's not closer to the sun yeah i'm not
just saying that it was also
invoked to explain some anomalies in the
motion of other things that's right
yes and that's frequently what happens
in science you know in my channel i talk
about the scientific method as not
really existing there is no one
scientific method uh there's multiple
approaches and sometimes you
serendipitously come across anomalies
and sometimes that's quite a fruitful
way to proceed and actually that
dovetails nicely into a question
by one of my viewers and friends on on
twitter
and that's uh that's a professor
in uh in the uk martin bauer who studies
uh particle physics but uh but martin
asks um there are galaxies for which the
rotation curves fit the baryonic matter
alone
in other words galaxies that have no
dark matter uh in them and so he's
asking
me to ask you
how do such galaxies that only have
ordinary baryonic matter how do they fit
in in the context of mond
so
first of all uh i suppose
you know mond uh predicts that the
discrepancy should kick in only at
acceleration below
we haven't discussed more than what it
is and so on
yet i could say
i didn't say what one did right okay
well actually why don't we start with
that then mordecai because we don't have
you have you have to go and you've been
very generous with your time it's
getting late there so let's start with
what is mond and then we'll get into
what things are perplexing about mond in
particular about
non-dark matter uh
candidates such as these galaxies so
first of all what is mond and then i'll
show some of the slides that you sent
right so the question the question is
okay if i said to try to modify
the laws of newton let us say
so to explain the
discrepancies without that matter you
have to take into account the fact that
everybody mentioned that these laws have
been verified and tested successfully in
the sort of victim in the lab
so you need to
ask yourself i mean what what what in
the what what what attribute of the
system
would tell you that
newtonian galactic is still correct
okay or when it is correct and when you
have to replace it with something else
okay so in fact my my issue was i i
looked for different
system attributes that you could use to
differentiate between the solar system
where newton's newton's laws from when
and galaxies
so after a long story
uh i i pinpointed on the accelerations
being the crucial focal piece of
accelerations accelerations in galaxy
are many orders of magnitude smaller
than what you encounter in the solar
system
introducing a new constant of nature
with a dimensional acceleration this
always happens you know when when we
introduce some departure from physics
like quantum physics it introduced a new
constant the planck's to understand and
in a way it is a marker it is a marks
the borderline between the validity
domain
of the old cov let's call it the
classical ocean and the museum
so in relativity this is played by the
speakers like in quantum mechanics by
plants constant in money displayed by
this acceleration from sky may not so so
in essence says that as long as
accelerations in the system
are much larger than the same watch
which is the case in the laboratory
standard physics holds very accurate in
newtonian galaxy in general
but when you go to much lower
acceleration
there is a disco there is a departure
and
yes this equation actually summarizes
the departure
so
i should explain it but uh
it's one one way of putting it
you you see this mu there if you just
ignore them the whole thing with the new
payoff that i know
you get f of the n equals a which is
just newton's second law which is
the force divided by mass is the
acceleration one introduces this
correction which can be very large
and uh
when the acceleration
a
becomes much smaller than this a naught
which is the constant of one this mu
becomes
much smaller than 1
which means
[Music]
right which means that
you need
well okay f here is the first calculated
q newton
right so given the the force calculated
by newton
when a is this a much more than a naught
this big this sort of volt a
becomes much larger than you would get
immediately and that is how the
discovery is uh
removed because
it says right the same
force actually
tells you that the
force is inserted
okay so i'm now ready to try to answer
the question
introduced before i think
that
what i just said
more or less enough
so of course there are i don't think he
means those directives but there are
galaxies or which is regions in galaxies
where the acceleration are still larger
than a node and then you don't expect to
see to see that method
okay you know i mean you don't expect to
see this happen
the language of dark matter because of
beijing dark matter you don't expect to
see that
but there have been claims in the yeah
yeah yeah okay so my short answer is i
just don't believe this
okay i can i can explain to you why in
so many words but
you don't believe that there's no dark
matter or you believe that the rotate
there's no
but
the interpretation of the measurements
is just incorrect and you know
that the the popular
literature tends to accentuate these
claims because the
the more spectacular they are the more
interesting they are for the readers
right but but there are also other
papers that
you know that explain why all this is
nothing
[Music]
okay so
so what they measure again as i
mentioned before in clusters
are they the one component of the
velocity
okay so only the one along the line of
sight which is measurable by the
operation but in order to estimate the
mass of the reality they need the
three-dimensional velocity
now they don't really know that the
velocities in the plane of the sky
are
larger than what they measure along the
back side for example this galaxy
specifically is rotating
but with such an inclination you know
it's more or less in the plane of the
sky you wouldn't know it
you will only
reduce your the mass just just based on
this one philosophy and it in fact there
are claims in the future that this
galaxy is worth taking
there's no problem
you know it's it's it's
but but uh yeah the basic answer is i
just don't
like and many others i should say and
there are papers about it i mean
actually there are much more mundane
explanations
right
that matter but never mind
and then um there's a question that's
occurred many times in the literature
and then in my audience tim johnson
who's a
friend of the show listens to the show
he's asking can you share your view on
why the bullet cluster is a challenge
for mond and how can it be explained by
mond
so first of all what is the bullet
cluster i'll show a picture of it on the
screen so the bullet cluster was not
a cluster or actually a pair of glasses
that
they've undergone a coalition we see
them just a few 100
i think million years after they
actually the centers went
through each other
here we see them on the sky what you see
here is uh i think the x-a picture
is these two clusters contain gas for
gas
this gas earlier it's more or less
invented again
[Music]
see that and
this map basically tells you uh
where
much of the value on sound but the
values are the standard method so
in clusters it is not to be dominated by
like the old gas so so essentially
you know
essentially they tell you what where
where the volumes are
now
what you can also
study this club this double cluster the
so-called weak gravitational lensing by
using the distortion of
the images of galaxies that are far
behind in the club in the background
behind this cluster
right so these are the two sort of
bluish things so the reddish things
are what we just saw before
the x-ray the x-ray emission from the
object and
this is where where
the hot glass
the bluish things are where the galaxy
in the clusters
so the cluster just went to each other
imagine itself that
the two clusters before they collided
contained this gas and galaxies mixed
together
but once they collided because the the
gas cloud
essentially cannot very easily go
through
each other because they're sticking
so they stay more or less near the
center but the gala that the clumps of
galaxies and the traffic just went
through
and you see that these two
okay so
however from studies of the
distortion of
images of galaxies behind the scene
we can tell where the dark matter is
okay we can tell
we can map essentially that the total
matter in the system and it turns out to
be where the galaxies are
okay so it's more about the bluish
things
so the claim is the following number you
say that you know according to monday
get the clay
[Music]
according to want
you know you should find sort of the
discrepancy you should find this phantom
or putative dark matter where the
volumes are
yes so but in this in this game in this
system they seem to be
not where most of the valiants are which
is the largest things but where the
bluish things are
okay so that was it was trendy that's
the proof of the existence of the
dark matter
so uh
the the answer our one answer is
right answers
several so first first of all
the problem was not
[Music]
that we already knew from the 90s that
one does not explain the way
completely that they must discuss the
same clusters of galaxies
okay this is still a standing issue this
morning
but
even much before the clusters and in
analysis
later we saw whatever there are several
other methods that show that if you
apply more to clusters
so in individual cluster not one that
can turn the one collision
there's also a discrepancy
it's it's let's say discrepancy of a
factor of standard perfect so the reason
the matter is just the tense of what's
needed
to supply the gravity right
so you you need like nine times more
attack method
if you apply more to this system it
reduces the the discrepancy greatly but
it still leaves a discrepancy factor of
two options
so you would still need in these
clusters not speaking about the the
bullet now just
just about uh
isolated
you would still need some components
that we haven't discovered yet
so some people prefer
to say that this is maybe sterile
neutrinos
that can fall into plastic but not into
galaxies because
the famous argument
they are too light
to fully develop
but my own uh
my look
okay my own
explanation is that yes clusters still
contain some bionic method that we
haven't detected yet
it's not initially
you only need you know as much as you
already see
and it could be in a component that
hasn't been discovered yet
i think that starts from cell population
because
quite a few papers
and
you you know we
you may know that there is also
something called the missing variance
problem
yeah we think we think what you know we
think we know what the total number of
values
in the universe is we know this one
nucleus in this formation of the
black elements and so on
so we think four percent of the closure
density of the universe is valued but
where are they i mean a tally
of baryons as we know them today
can account for roughly 60 percent of
the balance
okay so where where are they
50
and all that you need to explain away
the the problems
clusters
just about five percent if you some of
all clusters
and all that you need in clusters you
need about five percent of the values
but now it's six millimeters
i'm not saying that i know that this is
the answer that it could be an answer
he would very much like to know it is
still an issue i consider it an issue
an open question you want but one that
at least can have a simple explanation
and and i should say that okay if you
now know if you if you take what you
learned from
single classes right so they lasted and
then the the bruce lester just behaves
in the way that you expect
because
this extra component has to be non-dc
but
for other reasons and so when the two
truss is
[Music]
so um
looking at uh other challenges uh to
mond uh there are questions about other
types of dark matter uh you just brought
up one type you know sterile neutrinos
or axions um but i often point out
there's there's a detection of dark
matter at least that's been claimed uh
for over 22 years
and that's by the dhamma experiment and
i wonder can you give me your
perspective on dhamma
is it a challenge uh and just more
generally speaking if the liquid noble
gas detectors like xenon one ton which
is co-run here at uc san diego by my
friend and colleague and past guest
kaiswan knee and friend and past guest
alina april
are there uh challenges to mond if uh if
if dhamma is to be taken seriously
if let's start by saying that certainly
dark matter is detected
then it is the challenge it's not just
the challenge it's just
[Music]
sorry money it's a little hard to hear
you what did you
i'm saying that if dark matter is
actually discovered
that certainly it's a challenge
if particulate dark matter is detected
right yeah but but dhamma i mean
you don't have to ask me
ask anyone else
even those who believe in that right i
don't i don't think they uh
actually believe in dhamma
well as as you may know it conflicts
you know by many others of magnitude
with other experiments
there are also as far as they know
similar experiments using the same type
of detect detectors
that claim that they haven't seen
anything and
uh
there are mundane explanations but look
i'm not the right person to ask right i
have absolutely no idea of what could go
exactly could go wrong with dhamma and i
i don't have a way
yeah
but generally speaking right if there if
there was a
in other words is there no possibility
that both flowers could bloom both the
dark matter and particulate form
and a modification um or is it really
one or the other
well in principle it can be and as you
know
i watch bits of your interview with
sabine most influencer which in the case
at some point is advocated or endorsed
yeah hybrid ideas without mecca i should
say it's not the first uh it's the most
famous one
the people involved are more
local
but the similar ideas that we
suggested before
[Music]
[Music]
gravitationally polarize the medium such
that on large scales it works as dark
matter
and not small scales it
reproduces norms
and
so the fluid matter is the conceptually
at least the similar idea is that the
galaxies in the universe at large it's
uh
again filled with
extrude that could be either
standard
phase
in which case it works with dark matter
in the sense that it acts by its
gravitational wave gravitational pull
but that in galaxy that it can form a
superfluid state
and there it doesn't act mainly by its
gravitational pull but rather it
modifies the interaction between baryons
between stars and so on so as to
reproduce
the effects of moon
now these are hybrid hybrid models
i can't say that it cannot be but i
don't
i don't like them very much for the
force ever
on a steady ground you know it's like
the the easiest way out you see
you put together you stick together two
different things
that you know if you already have one uh
sort of outrageous idea
you know you want and you see succeed in
a large range of phenomena why not try
to improve it so it succeeds
right
when you put two such
things together you know they
they tend to fail
in the region where you stick them right
because okay this one works here the
other one what's there whatever
and um
[Music]
you know
this is a common a common thing that
there is i don't know it's not very
famous that at the time where there was
a struggle let's say between the
tournament
geocentric
picture
you know everything goes around the
earth including the sun
there seem to be advantages to this to
the two things
and so
put the hybrid
suggested behind me did you know about
it so i know he's very famous but he
said okay let's have all the planets
let's go around the sun except yes yeah
the hand with all its this entourage of
planets go around the earth
yes so he actually it has the benefits
of the of the copernican system
but at least as far as the parallaxes
were not yet observed so you know
parallax is working you know where there
are the clinching arguments for the
copernicus and then we're actually by
the motion it's the talent motion
of things on the sky we know that it is
the earth that goes on before that it
actually combined the benefits of
the
system with the those of the you know
the sun you could still be okay with the
bible tonight the sun goes around here
so it could stop it
it on and uh you know as this is the
bible dictator and it was the location
for others so it was a highly
but we we know we know what happened
there
so
you know i understand because i don't
um
well monty i know it's getting late
there and you've been so gracious with
your time and
and the audience questions answering all
the audience questions i want to ask you
one last question which
is pertinent to the name of the podcast
which comes from one of uh sir arthur c
clarke's famous
laws he actually had four of them and
they're controversial which what's the
naming what's the counting of them but i
want to ask you the one that's pertinent
to the name of my podcast which states
the following the only way of
determining the limits of the possible
is to venture beyond them into the
impossible so that's where the name of
the podcast comes from and i want to ask
you in the context that i ask all my
guests who are so gracious like you are
uh i want to ask you what gave you the
courage as a 20 year old or 30 year old
if you can go back to uh your former
self and give some advice some life
advice what would you say to give the
courage to go as you've done the hutzpah
into the impossible
yes well because this stream was
possible impossible actually
accompanied me along the order you know
because so many times i've heard this is
impossible this thing's possible with
month i mean yeah they said okay fine
one words for galaxies but it would be
impossible to explain
light bending and gravitational lensing
so it took 20 years but
there was finally the relativistic
theory that did
get
lengthy correctly and
then people say well but you can't get
the cnb
it's impossible to get the cnbc this
morning just last year there was created
by his police and blosney
suggesting a relativistic monsieur that
does reproduce the cnb fluctuation
from the very beginning for me this
possibly impossible
right before i know that you know when i
started thinking about it i i well i
didn't think it would be impossible but
i was sure that the probability is very
low that i will actually be able to
modify the
of course i'm like everyone else
not crazy
so i started i had this this idea the
initial idea
i said to myself well i'm sure in a day
or two i just showed that if it's wrong
i mean it's it's highly unlikely at
least
and then i would i would because because
it impinges on so many phenomena
i'm sure i'll find something bones
it didn't happen after a few days i
worked it out again and again
i invested more time and so on and and
every time
things that
initially looked impossible or just
highly important but turned out to be
possible and uh
yeah if if it's any of course it doesn't
this way of augmentation doesn't work so
in the individual
i i don't know how
good an idea is to just tell entirely
the impossible because chances are in
any case if it looks impossible
it's probably at least impossible so you
may be wasting your time but as a
community certainly i mean some of us
should try the what looks like
impossible otherwise we're not going to
get beyond the boundaries
right we already right so so for
individual so what is good as a general
advice for the
community
the community should always send
politicians should accept such people
you know with open open minds at least
we'll give trouble
when they're trying to do something like
this because it's very important for the
community to explore beyond
[Music]
i want to wish you la letove thank you
for coming here
yes
thank you very much yes any sufficiently
advanced technology
is indistinguishable from magic
[Music]
so
[Music]
you